[Musique]
elle était la mère de céline dion et
avec le temps maman dion est devenue une
icône pense que c'est un
un grand morceau du québec je pense que
madame dion était la maman la plus
célèbre au monde aux mondiaux ce
deuxième est pour tout le monde au
québec on est notre mère puisque notre
main et nous quitte simon madiot qui le
remplace et de la musique
maintenant reste à nos amis en gaspésie
au sein d'une famille modeste thérèse
tanguay a appris le violon à l'âge de 11
ans et c'est grâce à la musique qu elle
rencontre l'amour de sa vie
adhémar dion le couple a eu 14 enfants
dont la petite dernière céline dion
maman dion décèle rapidement le talent
de sa cadette a rare au québec d'avoir
une grosse famille mais c'est un petit
peu aujourd'hui je t'aime tu peux
anciennement voyez-vous maman dion est à
l'origine du phénomène céline dion elle
qui a co écrit la chanson ce n'était
qu'un rêve premier grand succès de la
chanteuse
et si elle qui va recruter rené angélil
le gérant qui a lancé la carrière de sa
fille
[Musique]
puis ça a été la première à croix ans
céline dion rené angélil et céline dion
ont toujours dit la première manager de
céline ça était madame dion un bref
moment diot a aussi des années de gloire
à la télévision elle avait son émission
intitulée tout simplement maman dion où
elle recevait des célébrités pour
partager sa passion de la cuisine il
offrait une forêt à la biardais j'étais
sa productrice d'émissions de télé et
quand je lui ai proposé d'animer une
émission andré dussault ma petite fille
j'ai toujours voulu faire ça à voulait
faire son argent donner son argent à qui
avoue l'air je cherche toujours à
apprend à écouter les gens
curieuse modeste et généreuse on lui
doit la fondation maman dion qui
soutient depuis près de 15 ans
l'éducation des enfants en milieu
défavorisé féministe elle gérait les
choses à sa manière
une bonne manière de ces personnes qui
t'aime mais qui fait comprendre que si
tu dois faire et ça c'était la fois aux
mondiaux y en avait peu de misère dans
l'auto de moins visible ces derniers
temps maman dion était malade depuis
plusieurs mois elle est décédée entourée
de ses enfants aujourd'hui sur les
réseaux sociaux
ils étaient nombreux à lui rendre
hommage dont le premier ministre du
québec
sa fille céline dion écrit que son
concert de ce soir lui est spécialement
dédié
les
[Musique]
ici louis philippe ouimet radio canada
montréal